[MUSIC PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]
EVAN RICH: All right.
So thank you for having us.
We're excited to be here.
This is actually our second
Google cooking demonstration.
So for those of you who
haven't been to one,
we have been to one.
They're amazing, OK?
[LAUGHTER]
Yeah.
So like you said,
we own Rich Table.
We opened it about six and a
half, almost seven years ago.
And it was just kind
of the restaurant
that we wanted to eat in and
the way that we wanted to dine.
So we've spent our lives working
in these really fine dining
restaurants that are super
serious about food, got
to get dressed up
to work in there,
and we never really felt that
comfortable going to eat there.
We loved cooking and thinking
about food in that way,
but the dining style
was just not really us.
I mean, I'm not the
most elegant person, OK?
[LAUGHTER]
SARAH RICH: What are
you talking about?
EVAN RICH: But with Rich
Table, we opened it up,
and it's more of a casual
kind of atmosphere, come
dressed how you are.
We bought an old
barn in Petaluma
and put it all over the
walls, made tables out of it.
And then we just kind
of cook what we crave.
We like to say we cook
with our stomachs.
So we change our
menu pretty often.
And anytime you
come in and see us,
you'll see the stuff we've
eaten on our days off.
So we'll do Korean stuff, we'll
do Chinese, we'll do French,
we'll do Japanese,
whatever we kind of feel,
and we'll just kind
of put our take on it.
People ask us what kind
of restaurant it is,
and we just say, we go to the
market, we see what's good,
we cook it, and
let our backgrounds
speak for themselves.
Before we were open, that
was a really difficult thing
for people to grasp onto
when they asked, oh, you're
opening a restaurant,
what kind of restaurant
are you opening up?
And it was just kind
of like, I don't know--
SARAH RICH: Food restaurant.
EVAN RICH: --we're
going to cook good food.
And they were like,
huh, interesting, OK.
We'll have to check that out.
SARAH RICH: PR
people don't really
like that kind of an answer.
EVAN RICH: Yeah.
So being in the
Bay Area, there are
a ton of vegetables,
ton of great products.
So we try and keep things
as simple as possible,
because it's real easy
to make delicious food.
It's difficult to
keep it simple.
We're chefs, so making
things really chefy
is pretty easy for us.
But once you sit
down and eat it,
it's kind of like, eh,
this is a little too much,
I'm not really getting it.
So the challenge for
us is kind of embracing
what the farmers cook out
here, keeping it simple,
but still making it
interesting enough
to have people come to our
restaurant every night.
SARAH RICH: Yeah.
And I would say, listening to
all the really lovely things
you had to say about
the restaurant,
it made me think about
seven years ago when
we were trying to put this
idea together and open
this restaurant, we had no idea.
You know, we had hopes
and dreams for it,
but we had no idea that it
would become what it is.
And we're really proud
and excited that we
have been able to
create this restaurant
that people really enjoy.
And so the cookbook
itself really
tells the story of how we
created the restaurant.
It's not just a book of recipes.
It tells the story of how we
met in New York, fell in love,
decided to take a chance on
California and move out here,
had a couple of kids
and opened a restaurant.
So I think there's a lot in
there that you can read about
and really relate to as well.
And so the recipes
in the book really
comprise the first maybe two or
three years that we were open.
And in that period
of time, we were
drawing from a lot of
personal influences,
whether it's restaurants
that we had worked in,
chefs we had worked with,
or family memories, which
is exactly where this
recipe came from.
Evan's grandmother was
Austrian and would make
a big Austrian meal on Sundays.
EVAN RICH: Sauerbraten
and potato pancakes
every other Sunday.
It was the most amazing.
SARAH RICH: They would do
Sunday supper together.
EVAN RICH: I was very
young so the sauerbraten
was a little weird to me.
But the potato pancakes dressed
with butter, and sour cream,
and applesauce were like--
I mean, I can
taste it right now,
it's the most amazing thing.
The funny thing
about the book is,
it took us about
three years to make.
So realistically, 90% of
those recipes in the book, we
don't actually do at
the restaurant anymore.
Because we take
versions of it and we're
always changing and evolving.
And so people come in now
and they're like, hey,
I want to try the
sweet potato pancake.
We're like, well, we got version
12 of the potato pancake,
how about you try this one?
But I like to think of the book
as a tool for everyone else
to have some great ideas and
then put your own take on, put
your own spin on it.
So the recipes are
really honed in
and the flavors are
nice and balanced.
And it makes it easy for you
guys to execute this stuff.
But as you'll see when
I make this recipe,
we'll kind of give
you some ideas
of how to make it your own,
or how to put your spin on it,
or how to just have fun with it.
So everyone always asks,
oh, what recipe did you use,
so-and-so?
And you're kind of like, I
don't know, we just kind of cook
and then we put
together recipes.
So these are good
baselines for everyone
to put together a good
repertoire of fun things
you can cook at home.
So today we're going to make
the sweet potato pancake.
So my lovely wife over here
is going to start the potato
pancake, OK?
So my grandmother
used to make them
which just russet
potatoes, but today we're
going to make them
with sweet potatoes.
So this is kind of
our version of it.
SARAH RICH: Yeah.
So I don't know if
any of you have ever
made potato pancakes, or latkas,
or anything like that before,
but it's basically
the same sort of idea
just using the sweet
potato instead.
So it'll have a little bit,
obviously kind of a sweeter
flavor, not so potatoey?
I don't know, for a
lack of a better--
so I've just got a regular box
grater, which you probably all
have access to.
And I've got my sweet potatoes.
These were really
pretty gigantic ones.
So they're cut smaller to
make it a little bit easier.
And I'm just going to grate it.
Just be careful of your fingers.
EVAN RICH: So we're doing
it with sweet potatoes,
but go to the market, see
what potatoes are available
and use those.
So white potatoes,
little creamer potatoes,
any kind of potato you want.
And you can even go as far
as like, oh cool it's winter,
they have a bunch of root
vegetables, I have kohlrabi,
I have radishes, I
have daikon radish.
Something that kind of
looks like a root vegetable
like this, you can
make this cake with.
So this is an ingredient you can
kind of mix and match and make
it your own as well.
With my grandmother's version,
she also did the potato
and then took a Vidalia onion
and grated it the same way
and mixed it all up, just
to bring another level
of sweetness to it.
But with the sweet
potato, the sweetness
is there, so we excluded the
onion so it isn't overly sweet.
SARAH RICH: All right.
So I'm just going to throw
the sweet potato into a bowl.
So I've got a couple of
things I'm going to add to it.
I'm going to crack this egg
and just whisk it a little bit.
EVAN RICH: And so right now,
you're almost making a batter.
So if you just put this
into the pan alone,
you could slowly cook
it and the starches
would help bring it together,
and it would kind of work.
But to make this, we're trying
to make almost like a cake.
So less of a crispy
potato pancake,
but more of an actual
pancake with potatoes in it.
SARAH RICH: So I
added some salt to it.
Anytime you season something,
I don't know if you noticed,
but I seasoned up
high and I seasoned
everything instead of just
throwing a big clump in there
and then going from there.
You want to really try
to get your seasoning
all over the place so that
you can incorporate it really
evenly.
If you throw your big clump
in there and mix it up,
you'll mix it in there, but
this is just a better way
to really incorporate it evenly.
This is just a little
cream of tartar.
And the egg.
EVAN RICH: The cream of tartar
just helps stabilize the egg
and make it more of a
cohesive package, I guess.
It's not that necessary, but
we just do it because we're--
SARAH RICH: Helps to keep the
egg from being super liquidy,
I guess.
And then this is wonder flour.
So wonder flour is a
special kind of flour
that it doesn't clump the
way regular flour does.
So it works really
nicely here so you
can avoid some of
that clumpyness
that you can get from flour.
You can find it in pretty
much all grocery stores.
It is really not hard to find.
But if you don't find it and you
just want to use regular flour,
you can do that too.
EVAN RICH: So it's
the type of flour
that you would get if
you're making gravy.
And at the end, instead
of putting AP flour
in which will clump,
you put it in at the end
and it thickens your gravy
up without having to make
a roux or anything like that.
So it just helps absorb
and it doesn't clump up.
SARAH RICH: What do
you think, more egg?
EVAN RICH: Yeah.
Yeah, looks good.
SARAH RICH: OK.
I'm just checking.
EVAN RICH: I'm the
sous-chef here,
I don't know why
she's asking me, OK?
[LAUGHS]
SARAH RICH: All right.
So that's all mixed
really nicely.
I don't know if you can see.
So whenever you have
something like this
that it's got
something raw in it,
whether it's a meatball or
hamburger, you've got raw meat
or you've got raw egg
and you don't really
want to taste it like this to
see if it's seasoned properly,
you can just cook
a little bit of it
first and then taste it
yourself, see what you think.
Add more salt if you
need, or not if you don't.
EVAN RICH: OK.
So with this dish,
with everything we do,
there's a formula, right?
I'm sure with what
you do every day,
you have a formula
of how to execute
things and stuff like that.
So with our cooking, there are
a few formulas that we use.
So one is flavor base.
So sweet, salty, acidic,
and bitter, right?
So mixing these flavors
together in a dish
really help bring out
flavors, but there's also
a textural thing.
So creamy, crunchy,
creamy and crunchy
are usually my
balance, and then just
kind of everywhere in between.
So the potato kind of
has a mix of all that.
But we're also going to
add another layer of it
with some potato chips, OK?
So it just brings
another layer of flavor
and another layer of
complexity, right?
So part of making
dishes interesting
is bringing these
layers of complexity.
And keeping it simple
is what we try and do,
and texture brings
another layer.
And the way that we're going
to cook these potato chips,
it just brings another
flavor to the sweet potato
that help elevate the dish.
So I'm just slicing
these on the mandolin.
So basically making sweet
potato chips, real simple.
I mean, it's very easy.
We've got a pot of
oil on the stove.
That's probably about
low to medium high.
SARAH RICH: 350, about.
EVAN RICH: 350.
You don't want to go too hot,
because it'll burn the chips.
So sweet potatoes have
a lot of sugar in them,
so too hot on the pan,
too hot in the frying oil
will burn them really quickly.
So you want to go low and slow.
And so the oil is
just barely bubbling
when I drop everything in there.
And so it'll be perfect.
So I just want to kind
of let them go real slow.
They'll cook nice and evenly
and they won't really brown up.
And there is a moment
when they're perfect,
and then two seconds later,
they're a little too dark.
SARAH RICH: And I would say,
we give you a temperature guide
and we say about 350, but
just use your instinct.
As you're cooking, if that
seems to be a little high,
depends on how much sugar
is in the actual potato,
they're all different.
How thick you cut it, all of
those things can affect it.
So just, maybe you need
to turn it down a little,
maybe you need to
turn it up a little.
Don't just take our word
specifically exactly
to be right.
EVAN RICH: And so
if you're going
to make this specific
dish or a dish like it,
these are something
you can definitely
make ahead, put them on the
side, and just have them ready.
Because a lot of the cooking
we do, you cook it to order
and then you serve it.
So something like
this, the potato
pancakes if you're
making this at home,
you're going to want to
cook the potato pancakes,
plate them up, serve
them, and eat them.
You can make the potato pancakes
and reheat them in the oven.
But the best way to do it
is to cook them, serve them.
At my grandmother's
house on Sunday,
my grandmother would
be in the kitchen
making the potato pancakes and
putting out batches, coming
back, eating a little bit,
go back into the kitchen,
cook some more potato pancakes.
SARAH RICH: Yeah.
EVAN RICH: So depending on
what you're trying to do
or how many people you're
cooking for, you kind of want
to just like, OK cool,
I'm going to cook these,
I'll have everything else
ready, and then we'll
plate everything up.
SARAH RICH: But
you can also have
an oven on a low
temperature with a nice--
put a pan in there so the pan
gets warm, like a cookie sheet.
And you can cook one,
two, three, four of these,
as you cook them
put them in the oven
so they stay nice and warm.
You're not heating them,
you're not reheating them,
you're just keeping
them nice and warm
and then plate them right
away and send them out.
EVAN RICH: OK.
So while she's getting
all the pans ready
and these are frying,
I'm going to start
making the salsa verde.
And so salsa verde,
to me, is one
of these sauces that
I make very often
and a bunch of
different versions.
One of the things we always
like to have on a dish
is something bright and fresh.
And a salsa verde, to me, is
one of these things that's
just really light,
really bright,
and just brings a really,
really nice element to a dish.
So you can make it a
bunch of different ways.
But the way we
usually start it off
is with some
shallots and garlic.
And so the texture in this
sauce is important to me,
so I don't want to mince
things up too much.
In the cookbook, we tell you to
put it all into the Robot Coupe
and it works perfect.
But when you do-- so that's
the Robot Coupe right there.
So when you do it, you
just want to get everything
in and quickly pulse
it, like [VOCALIZING],,
and not break everything
down too soupy.
So I like to do it by hand.
And I think when we
made the cookbook,
we were just trying to
think about the people who
are cooking at home.
But if you're not
making too much of this
or cooking for too many
people, doing it by hand
is really easy.
And it shouldn't be a problem.
So I just mince
up some shallots.
SARAH RICH: I'm going to stop
you while you're doing that.
EVAN RICH: Yeah, yeah, go ahead.
SARAH RICH: I'm going
to go ahead and start
cooking the pancakes.
So I've got a little bit
of olive oil and butter
in the pan.
I put the olive oil in
first, just to kind of--
I'm warming up the
olive oil, but it's also
keeping it kind of
a low temperature
so that when I add the butter,
there's less of a chance
that I'm going to
burn the butter.
I don't want to get
really color on it.
That can be really good
flavor, but that's not really
the flavor I'm looking for here.
But the flavor of the
olive oil and the butter
will be nice with the pancake.
So I'm just going to put
some of the mixture in there,
adjust my temperature.
A lot of cooking is really just
about adjusting temperature.
You're constantly like, oh
it's getting a little too warm,
it's browning on the edges.
Or it's not warm enough, I need
to go up, I need to go down.
Don't just turn on the stove and
walk away and say that's right.
You're constantly
looking and adjusting.
OK, back to you, Evan.
EVAN RICH: And so for me
with this salsa verde, so
in my mind, salsa
verde is a raw sauce.
So we do raw
shallot, raw garlic.
And raw garlic in
it is really nice,
because it just has this spice
and this kick to it that really
brings a nice element,
and it works really well
with this dish.
And so in the cookbook,
there is an actual recipe.
So I usually just throw
it together and taste it.
So just read the recipe.
SARAH RICH: Yeah.
[LAUGHTER]
EVAN RICH: And
then for this one,
we're going to do
some raw arugula.
And so this just arugula
you can find anywhere.
I suggest you go to the
market and you taste through
and find the spiciest one
that works really well.
But we also make salsa
verdes with cilantro,
we make it with kale,
we make it with cabbage.
It's more of a way to use raw
green vegetables that help
bring a nice element to a dish.
SARAH RICH: It's a
really nice sauce
to use on pretty much anything.
EVAN RICH: Steak, potatoes.
SARAH RICH: Steak,
chicken, vegetables.
EVAN RICH: We actually just
put a new version of this dish
on the menu last night.
And it's not a potato
pancake, but it's roasted
young potatoes that we
got at the market with a--
SARAH RICH: It's really good.
EVAN RICH: --sour cream
potato puree on the bottom,
a little salsa verde trout
roe, and then potato chips.
So it's this, but kind of
taken apart and put together.
The flavor is all the same.
SARAH RICH: We have another
recipe in the cookbook that's
a roasted cauliflower
that's got a bone marrow
salsa verde and kumquats,
that's really nice too.
EVAN RICH: And so you
want to chop it up nice
so it becomes a
nice sauce, but you
don't want to go too much,
because then all of a sudden it
turns into mulch and it starts
tasting like lawn clippings
and stuff like that.
And the idea is--
SARAH RICH: It's not the
flavor you're looking for.
EVAN RICH: Yeah.
Well the idea is, you're using
all this raw fresh ingredients,
and you want to taste that
raw fresh ingredient, right?
Like, arugula is amazing, that's
why you put it on everything.
But if you cook it,
the flavor goes away.
If you chop it up too
much, it tastes like grass.
And so you don't want
to chop it up too much,
but you want to chop it
up enough so that when
you add all the olive
oil and stuff like that,
it comes together like a sauce.
So then this other
green is parsley.
And this just brings
a nice green flavor.
So for me, parsley
is just this like,
when you say something green, I
think of the flavor of parsley.
Actually one of the
restaurants I used to work at,
we used to make a parsley sauce
that we would call chlorophyll.
And it was just like,
we'd make it and then
incorporate it into all
these green purees that
would just turn it green.
And it was just
basically enhancing
that green flavor,
that green color,
and it just worked really well.
So this helps the freshness
of the dish, to me.
OK.
So I have parsley, arugula,
shallots, and garlic.
And then for this one, we're
going to add dried apricots.
So dried apricots
are an ingredient
I really love to use.
So we get them at
the farmer's market.
And it's something that
they grow in California,
and they dry them out,
and it's a great product.
And it also has this nostalgic
kind of feeling for me,
because when we were
young, I don't know,
I used to eat dried apricots,
my mom would give them to me.
SARAH RICH: You've got
mom and grandmom here.
EVAN RICH: They'd be so proud.
SARAH RICH: Yeah.
EVAN RICH: And it also brings
this really sweet acidic note
to the salsa verde.
So the potato pancake
is really heavy,
and sweet potatoes
are full of flavor.
You want to pull those out?
SARAH RICH: Yeah.
EVAN RICH: And so you need
something to break that up.
And this whole
sauce is the element
of the dish that's
going to break it up.
And so in the cookbook, it
says to just throw these right
into the food processor
and kind of pulse them up
and it creates a nice
little dice for everything.
And that's great.
But cutting them by
hand, I like to leave
them a little bit bigger.
Because when you're
eating the whole dish,
you want these nice little
pops of sweetness and acidity,
and it really works nicely.
So I don't really chop them
up, I just kind of dice them
smally.
You having trouble with that?
SARAH RICH: Yeah.
EVAN RICH: Yeah?
SARAH RICH: There we go.
It's only a million
people watching me.
EVAN RICH: Yeah, right?
[LAUGHTER]
SPEAKER 1: Quick question
for the audience.
So I'm curious, how
many people like
to cook at home, raise of hands?
How many people cook at
home at least once a week?
Keep them up.
Twice a week?
Three times a week?
SARAH RICH: Nice.
SPEAKER 1: That's awesome.
EVAN RICH: Wow.
SPEAKER 1: I had a quick
story while they're there
cooking here.
That before we opened
the teaching kitchens,
we actually had Googlers that
would never cook at home,
and I'm sure it still happens.
And we realized at
that point that we
should open some
teaching kitchens,
because we were serving
you too much food.
Keep up the great work.
EVAN RICH: Well so, with
this potato pancake,
it's important you
just go low and slow
and just kind of let
it all come together.
So the potato itself
has so much sugar in it
that if the heat is too
high, it will start burning.
But I don't know, I guess you
guys can't-- a little bit,
but it's just nice
and caramelized here.
And you want it to go slow
so that the potatoes cook
and everything comes together.
But if you go too high,
it'll start burning.
The dark flavor is good.
So you can go a little higher
and get it a little darker.
And that's that bitter element
that you want in the dish.
But going too fast
and too far, it
will just start tasting burnt,
and that's not what you want.
OK.
So I have my diced apricot,
parsley, arugula, garlic,
and shallot.
And then I'm basically just
going to put it into a bowl.
And so we've done this
with dried cherries,
you can do it with raisins.
Whatever you're-- this
is the basic formula.
So we have nice fresh, a
little bitter from the garlic,
and the onion, the arugula,
everything comes together.
And then that dried
fruit just helps
create a nice, bright,
acidic note to it.
And so I'm just going to
add some extra virgin olive
oil to it.
So at the restaurant, we only
use California olive oil.
So I like to think of it as,
the Italians flood the market
with really crappy olive oil.
But then Californians
really grow
some passionate,
beautiful olive oil.
So we just go to the
market and we find some.
We actually use one that we get
at the ferry building, Sciabica
and Sons, and they make a
great extra virgin olive
oil that's called Sevillano.
We only use two olive
oils at the restaurant,
so the Sevillano
and then they make
another one called 8020, which
is kind of a cooking olive
oil that is like
a second pressing,
so the smoke point
is a lot higher.
And that's the only oil that
we use at the restaurant.
OK, so I added just enough
olive oil to make it a sauce.
And this is actually
better when you make it
a little bit further ahead.
Because you want everything
to meld together,
you want it to marinate,
you want it to sit.
You don't want to
make it too far ahead,
because the color
will start to go away
and it won't be so
bright and fresh.
But definitely make it--
chips and this, make
it an hour or so ahead,
put it aside, and then have
your party or do whatever,
and then make your stuff.
You all right?
SARAH RICH: Mm-hmm.
It's amazing.
EVAN RICH: And then it's
not in the cookbook,
but depending on what the
dried apricots taste like,
or whatever you're
putting in there,
I always like to put a
little bit of acid in there.
So champagne vinegar is
one of these vinegars
that's super strong acidity.
So rice wine vinegar is a little
less acidic and more sweet.
Sherry vinegar is a little
sweeter with less acidity.
And I just find that champagne
has the brightest note,
so you don't have
to put so much in
and it just gives a
nice pop of acidity,
which helps break up the
richness of the whole potato
pancake.
So I'm just going to put a
couple of drops in there,
mix it up, add a
little salt. And you
have to be careful, as
soon as you add that acid,
it'll start turning
the green brown.
And so not adding
it too far ahead,
or just adding it to order, is
probably the best way to do it.
So it'll sit here for maybe an
hour or two and it'll be fine,
but after that, it'll
start turning the green,
turning the arugula
and the parsley brown.
Which you don't want, because
it'll just ruin the flavor.
OK, so that's good,
that's ready to go.
We'll just let that
marinate while we
take on the rest of the dish.
So while Sarah's
finishing up the--
SARAH RICH: I'm just going
to go right on the plate.
EVAN RICH: OK.
And so this is a dish
that speaks to right now.
So right now, the season
is cold and rainy.
So sweet potatoes-- vegetables
become sweet in the winter
because they protect
themselves from freezing
by creating glucose
in themselves,
which is sweet to us.
So at night when it's super
cold, they don't freeze.
And so the sweet potatoes
are great this time of year.
And then also,
with all the rain,
all these green vegetables
are starting to come up.
So this is part of a family
called brassica, which
is like my favorite vegetable.
So cauliflower, broccoli,
cabbage, Brussels sprouts,
and they just have this
great sweet flavor.
So I love sweet vegetables.
And sprouting broccoli is--
I guess you kind of think
of this as a bitter green,
but actually this time
of year it's super sweet,
and it is really great.
So any type of sprouting
broccoli or sprouting vegetable
like this will really
work for this dish.
So we just do this real simple.
We take some boiling
water and some salt.
And so when you're cooking
green vegetables, the key--
so when you're in
culinary school,
they teach you, large amounts
of salted boiling water.
Large amounts of
salted boiling water.
So with green vegetables,
the object of cooking them
is to make them tender
and get them ready to eat.
But if you put too many in
a pot-- so when they cook,
they admit some kind of acid.
I forget the exact name of it.
But if they're too
much in the pot,
the acid drips back in and
that turns the vegetable brown.
Or if you put a lid on
it, the acid drips back in
and it turns the
vegetable brown.
So you want to cook them
as quick as possible,
so that's where the rolling
salted water comes in.
So the salt brings the
temperature up a little bit
and it makes the water
a little bit hotter
than it would without the salt.
And just drop the vegetables in
and let them cook
really quickly.
So normally, if you're not
going to use them right away,
you would have an ice
bath and cool them down.
But we're going to
use them right away,
and I'm going to take
it the next step that's
not in the cookbook.
So in the cookbook, it tells
you to just blanch them and then
dress them with the
salsa verde and serve it.
But today, we're going to take
it another step just to show
you how to step your game up.
SARAH RICH: And I'm
seasoning a little extra salt
on top of the pancake when
it came out of the pan,
just so that it seasons
it a little bit more.
EVAN RICH: All right.
So you want to cook them tender.
You don't want to cook them
too much, because they'll be--
a little texture
with your vegetable
is actually delicious.
So just a little bit
of olive oil in a pan.
So what I'm going to do is, I'm
going to take them out of this
and put them right into this.
And this is just going to
bring a little bit more flavor.
SARAH RICH: Yeah.
EVAN RICH: So brassicas,
sprouting broccoli
or whatever it is, a little
caramelization on them
really brings out the sweetness
and it tastes really great.
That's why if you eat
fried Brussels sprouts,
they're so amazing.
Because they just have
that caramelized flavor
because all that
sweetness comes out
and it's just really amazing.
So if you learn that
and you figure out
with brassicas you can just
caramelize them a little bit
and they elevate that
flavor to the next level,
it's super easy.
So eating them
like this is great.
They taste delicious
and they're fine.
But I'm just going to take
them out of the water.
You don't want to get too
much moisture in that pan,
because it'll flame up or--
SARAH RICH: And he's not
cooking it in the pan,
he cooked it in here.
He's just wanting to get
a little caramelization
over there.
EVAN RICH: That's why I
want to go pretty hot.
SARAH RICH: He wants to
go as fast as possible.
EVAN RICH: And I want
to go in a hot pan
and just help bring
it to the next level.
Just caramelize it
just a touch just
to help bring out some of that
sweetness of the vegetable.
Cook them a little
bit further and make
them even more delicious.
Sorry.
All right, so we're
going to start
creating this dish for you.
Sour cream?
So for me, eating
the potato pancakes,
I always dreamt sour cream, and
applesauce, and tons of butter.
And so we try and be
a little bit lighter,
where there's olive oil, and
fresh vegetables and stuff
like that, and kind of
think about it a little bit
differently.
So I put a little
bit of the sour cream
on it, just because that element
of creaminess and richness
really helps with the
way the dish eats.
But if you want to
do a little butter
or if you want to omit
this all together,
there's plenty of fat
from the olive oil.
So right there, you
see there's just
a little bit of
caramelization on everything.
And it almost looks
like it's burning,
but that's bringing a
lot of flavor to it, OK?
So I'm just going
to turn that down.
SARAH RICH: Yeah.
I would say generally speaking,
when you're browning things,
you want to take it further than
you really think that you do.
People tend to get really
nervous that they're
going to burn things.
But that dark flavor is
what is really delicious.
So be adventurous, take
it a little further.
EVAN RICH: OK, so
with this broccoli,
the way we like to serve it is I
like to dress it with the salsa
verde, just because
it helps incorporate
that flavor of the salsa
verde with everything.
And spread it out.
And so just real simple,
right out of the pan, and I
just dress it up a little bit.
It just kind of helps bring
everything to another place.
SARAH RICH: And it helps the
whole dish come together.
So instead of having a
pancake, and some broccoli,
and some salsa verde, you're
eating them all together.
EVAN RICH: And so this, if
you also have a nice big pan,
this is a great dish to do
family style where you can just
make a bunch of small
pancakes or a big pancake
and put it on a big plate and
have a pile of green vegetables
on it.
Sauce the salsa verde, and
it works out really well.
But it's also great individual.
And so I'm just going
to put a little bit more
of the salsa verde on there.
And then this is the next
layer of texture in there.
So if you think about what's
going on in this dish,
there's a ton of
texture, there's
a ton of flavor going on.
But it's all very simple
and straightforward.
And then I always like to
finish with some fresh greens.
And it's all the same flavors.
We're kind of just layering all
these flavors from this dish
onto the same kind of platform.
But it's just different
layers of flavor,
different layers of texture.
SARAH RICH: Sometimes
at the market
you can get the
flowering broccoli,
you can actually
get the flowers.
And those are edible, and you
can put those on the plate,
and that's really pretty.
They're really bright yellow.
EVAN RICH: It's coming up
really soon when you can
get all that flowering stuff.
Because in the
winter, the rain comes
and it makes all those
beautiful green vegetables,
and sprouting.
And right at the end
of winter, that's
when everything
starts flowering.
SARAH RICH: It's called spring.
[LAUGHTER]
Sorry.
EVAN RICH: But it's
coming up very soon.
And actually, people get
a little nervous about it.
At the market, you'll
go to the market
and see all these bunches
of like sprouting broccoli,
but they'll have all
the flowers in it.
It's one of my favorite
times of the year,
because it's such a
sweet lovely flavor.
And at the end you
can put a couple on,
but you can also saute it up.
And it's just a really
beautiful thing to cook.
And so then, just a
couple leaves of parsley.
SARAH RICH: It's beautiful.
EVAN RICH: And if you
really think about it,
this represents
winter right now.
So it's like this
orange, this green.
This to me is winter
in the Bay Area.
This is something I
would love to eat,
and it's kind of a
soul warming thing.
Where winter in the Bay
Area isn't this really heavy
overwhelming, but it's cold,
but it's green, it's wet,
it's fresh.
And this is like, to
me, all the flavors
and the feeling of winter.
SARAH RICH: And you know
what, it's totally vegetarian.
Not necessarily everybody
eats vegetarian,
but I think people
try to eat less meat,
or look for different
ways to eat vegetables.
Not just a salad,
or some stir fry.
This is another
really interesting way
to eat vegetables.
SPEAKER 1: We have a lot
of chefs in our program
here that are really
trying to focus
on making vegetables as
craveable and desirable
as possible.
And just to highlight some
of the things you said,
you've got beautiful colors,
because we eat with our eyes
first.
You've got amazing
contrast in texture.
Obviously the aroma.
Can you smell this in the back?
You're going to
taste it a minute.
The aroma, the
textures, the color,
all these different
attributes are just
amazing to be able to have
something, as you put it,
so desirable and
highlight the vegetable.
And for people that
want to put meat
on top of it, of course
you probably could.
Why would you?
But that's just beautiful.
Huge round of
applause, everyone.
[APPLAUSE]
So we are going to open this
up to a few minutes of Q&A. I
have the first question.
So if you have questions,
just raise your hand.
And then I'll ask the chefs
to repeat the question out.
So you mentioned
you have children,
and I don't know
how old they are.
But I'm interested in your
current or future approach
to how you're going to engage
your children with food.
And the reason I answer
that is, probably
many mothers and
fathers in the room,
but we went through
a long time where
parents had to go back to
work, and it was very hard
for them to be able to
cook with their kids.
There's nothing harder than
being chefs, and restaurateurs,
and cookbook authors.
How are you going to
factor that in to be
able to expose your children?
Or are you going to be like,
kids, stay out of the kitchen,
find your own profession?
EVAN RICH: No, no.
They've got a job waiting
for them washing dishes, OK?
SARAH RICH: They can't wait.
EVAN RICH: They're
waiting, just waiting.
I'll let her go into it.
But from my view of it,
I mean, everyone always,
my kids will never cook, no way,
I'm going to push them away.
I mean, I really love
what I do and I enjoy it.
I'm not going to push
my kids to do what I do.
But if they're
interested in it, I'm
definitely going to
be excited and help
them navigate through
and develop themselves
as people who have a great
career and push through it.
SARAH RICH: So we have two
boys, they're seven and four.
And everybody always says,
oh, you guys are chefs,
your kids must eat so well.
They must be so adventurous
with their eating.
No.
They are children, they are
picky just like all children.
EVAN RICH: They are adventurous
with the dino nuggets.
SARAH RICH: Yeah.
So I guess the approach
has really been,
there are times where I
cook more adventurous stuff
and I expect that
they at least try.
And there are other
times where, yeah, we
eat dino nuggets, or
soup, or whatever.
But the thing that
we really have found
is that if you involve them
in the process of cooking,
they are much more
likely to eat it.
They get excited about being a
part of doing that, of helping
you, of having a task.
It makes them feel
confident and excited to be
helping mommy or daddy.
And then they're much more
interested in eating the food.
EVAN RICH: I have a tendency
to cook a lot of vegetables
when I'm home cooking, just
because at the restaurant
I eat pastas and steak.
You know, I'm tasting
all this stuff.
And when I come home
for the weekend,
I usually cook
really light stuff
that we've just
gotten at the market.
And one day I made this
cauliflower vegan salad, kind
of roasted, blah, blah, blah.
And I had both of the kids
with me the whole time
cutting tomatoes, or cutting
the onions, and doing this.
And it's a dish that
normal kids and my kids
included would like, [GROANS].
But incorporating them into
the cooking process of it,
they were so excited, and they
ate like, three bowls of it.
SPEAKER 1: Awesome.
Yeah, that's great.
How many people here have
kids and involve them
in the kitchen?
Awesome.
So any questions
from the audience?
I can keep going, but
I want to open this up.
Yes, in the back?
AUDIENCE: You did the thing
with the [INAUDIBLE] broccoli.
EVAN RICH: Uh-huh.
AUDIENCE: I'm really
curious how you
do that with Brussels sprouts.
It's hard to get--
I mean, do you get really
young Brussels sprouts then?
EVAN RICH: I mean, you can get
just regular Brussels sprouts
and do it the same way.
There's a great farmer at the
market called [INAUDIBLE],,
and they have Brussels sprouts.
And they're big, they
seem almost bigger
than you would think
Brussels sprouts should be.
And if you blanch them
real quick and just sear
them just like that,
maybe take the whole thing
and cut them in half and blanch
them and then sear them--
actually in the
cookbook, there is
a recipe for a
Brussels sprout Caesar
that we do at the restaurant.
And we just take Brussels
sprouts, cut them in half,
and then put them in a
pan with the face down
and slow cook them.
And we put a lid on it to
help get everything going,
and the sweetness
comes out really well.
SARAH RICH: Also to create a
lot of that caramelization,
getting a lot more surface area.
So if you just take the Brussels
sprout and you can shave it,
you can use a mandolin, just
like the mandolin like this
to shave it.
Or you can cut it
up really thinly,
and then you have
a lot more that you
can get touching the pan
that you can caramelize it.
I do that sometimes,
that works too.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
SARAH RICH: Mm-hmm.
SPEAKER 1: Again, fire away.
So another quick question
till the next hand goes up.
So in the book, you
mentioned that you
wanted Rich Table to really
be an extension of your home.
A couple of questions would be,
why was that important to you?
And then, what elements
in the restaurant
have you done to actually
bring that to life?
EVAN RICH: Well, I think
Rich Table is our home.
SARAH RICH: We're
there all the time.
SPEAKER 1: Fair.
EVAN RICH: So we opened the
restaurant because this is what
we've-- we've done
this our whole life.
I've never had any other
job other than cooking.
In some form or another, cooking
or in a restaurant, that's all
I've ever done.
So that's the only thing
that I know how to do.
And in the restaurant
business, you work a lot.
So we met working,
she was my boss.
We've built this
world for ourselves,
that the restaurant is our home.
Not only just an extension
of it, but it is our home.
And we wanted you to come
in and feel the warmth,
and be able to communicate, be
able to interact, be able to--
we work the pass or work in the
kitchen, but we deliver food,
and we talked to guests,
and the kitchen's open.
And it's extension of our
home because the people
we work with, we spend
a lot of time with.
We have great relationships
with our whole team.
And this is literally
part of our life.
So we wanted that
feeling when you come in.
And I think, it wasn't so much
building different elements,
it was more the people we work
with, the style of food we do,
the style of service, and
the style of restaurant
is just you come in and you
feel like you're coming to it.
A lot of the dishes we
do at the restaurant
are things we've cooked
at home for dinner
that we then develop into a dish
that we cook at the restaurant.
SPEAKER 1: I love that.
There's so many places
you can go to eat
and choices you need to make.
And the why behind what they
do I think is so important.
So thank you for sharing
that, it's very personal.
We had a question in the
back and then in the front.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
You talked about
going into the market
and seeing what
looks really fresh.
Especially for those of us
we come home after a long day
or it's a busy weekend, what's
a good approach to walking
into a market and
saying, OK, I'm
going to make a new
recipe from what
I see here that
looks really good,
especially if we're in a rush?
EVAN RICH: Well, so
keeping it simple, right?
So I mean, it's easy
for me to be like,
oh, just go to the market,
see what's good and cook it.
But really, if you
went to a market
and saw a bunch of
greens, it's like,
cool, I'm going to steam
rice, blanch them, saute them,
season them with a little
shoyu and toasted sesame
and put it over rice.
I mean to me, that's delicious.
And the more experience you have
cooking those type of things
at home, and just
feeling comfortable,
I know how to cook
beets, I'm going
to get a bunch of beets
and maybe just mess
around a little bit.
The reason why we do what
we do is just experience,
like flavor building, technique
in cooking, memories we have.
And we just build
these things together
and what they experience.
So going to the market, it
might be a little difficult
or daunting at first.
But it's like, just
keep it simple.
The food you're going
to get at the market
is delicious no matter what.
So a baby cabbage that
you just sear and put
a little vinaigrette
on, that's great.
SARAH RICH: I think
all of that goes
back to what he talked about
at the beginning in terms
of, we think a lot about
acid, and sweetness,
and bitterness, and texture.
Like the example
of the rice dish,
the rice is sort of
a creamy nuttyness.
You've got the
greens on top, you've
got the saltiness
from the soy sauce.
You've got something a little
crunchy, the sesame is crunchy.
So if you think in
those terms, what
is a texture that I
can bring to this?
It doesn't have
to be complicated.
You're more building on these
basic flavors and ideas.
EVAN RICH: Yeah.
You build your equation
in your head of the things
you like to eat.
And then it's like,
cool, instead of broccoli
I can get collard greens.
Instead of this I can get that.
And just think about
the different things.
SARAH RICH: And it's
trial and error too.
You will make things that--
I mean, we do.
We make things that
we're like, huh--
EVAN RICH: I've never made
anything that tasted bad.
SARAH RICH: --that wasn't great.
[LAUGHTER]
EVAN RICH: I've never
over-cooked anything.
SARAH RICH: I do the same
thing with dessert too.
I think about dessert
in the exact same terms.
I think about texture,
I think about acidity,
I think about saltiness.
All of those things
go into what make--
whether it be savory
or sweet, balanced,
and whole, and delicious.
SPEAKER 1: I want to highlight
the approach that they're
using when they're
going to the market
and realizing what's out
there to build their menu.
Very similar to your question,
because not all chefs
think that way.
A lot of chefs say, I want
to put this, this, and that
on the menu because
it would be good.
But it may not be in the market,
may not be at its height.
So I appreciate that question,
because you're really
supporting all
those great farmers
and suppliers that are out there
with the best that's out there.
I think chef made a great
point, keep it simple.
Because you don't want to come
back with 16 bags of stuff
if you're only cooking for two.
So good tip.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
So many of us have
heard how hard
it is to be a chef in a
restaurant and in kitchens.
What kind of culture do you like
to instill in your kitchen--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
SPEAKER 1: Culture, love it.
EVAN RICH: I scream at everyone
and demean them to the-- no.
So that's an extension
of what I was
talking about about our home.
So it's like, the
cooks, I probably
see the cooks more
than I see my kids.
I mean, my kids just learned who
I was maybe a year and a half
ago.
They thought I was the grumpy
guy who slept in the back room.
So it's important to
have a culture that--
so it's a balance, right?
So there is a level of
professionalism, drive,
motivation, and intensity.
Because we take our
jobs very serious.
Being a cook in our restaurant
is not a sustainable job.
You don't take a cook job
and you're like, cool,
I've got the best job and
this is what I'm going to do.
It's, I've taken this job
so I can learn, grow, build,
move on, so that I can
find my path as a chef.
And so there is a
level of intensity.
I don't want to say
there's yelling,
but there is definitely
very straightforward
blunt conversations of like,
do it like this, I don't care,
don't talk, go.
Because in the kitchen,
it moves very quickly.
When we're cooking for the
guests who are there, it's not,
cool, we have 20 minutes.
Re-do that, let's
think about this.
It's, hey, this dish is
up, there paying for it,
let's go, it needs to be right.
There is a level of that where
demeaning someone, or talking
down, or being a
yeller is horrible.
It's like, I don't want
that, I don't need someone
talking to me like that.
I take the approach of,
I talk to people the way
I want to be talked to.
And we have a great environment,
I have a great relationship
with all of our cooks.
SARAH RICH: We've
also both worked
in those kitchens where
people are screaming,
people are mean to each other,
people sabotage each other.
It's cutthroat, everybody's
out for everybody else's job.
And that's not what we want
our kitchen to feel like.
And like Evan says,
it's very fast paced,
sometimes you have to
be short with people,
there's not time to mess around.
But I think that
aside, I think we have
created a really nice culture.
We want our team to
feel like a team,
we want them to feel like
they're working together.
They're not working
against each other.
EVAN RICH: We put a
lot of energy into it.
Because the longer people
stay, the better you can build.
I always say to every new cook
who comes in or new person,
this is the circle.
If we live in here, we're
joking around, we're having fun,
we're doing what we need to
do, everyone's progressing--
SARAH RICH: And as a
diner, you can sense that,
and you can taste that,
and you can feel that.
I'm sure you have been to
restaurants where you walk in--
I know I have--
and you see the kitchen
and they're like--
EVAN RICH: Just feel the stress.
SARAH RICH: They're
scared that they're
going to get screamed at.
You see the servers who look
like they hate their lives.
A guest can feel
that and taste it.
And you don't want to
create that for anyone.
EVAN RICH: Yeah.
I mean, I've actually
learned over the years
that the more you focus
on the inside culture
and the enjoyment of the
staff, the better that
translates to the guest.
I guess in the beginning, I
was always like, the guest,
the guest, the guest,
and didn't really think
about the staff or the
culture and stuff like that.
And then just over the
years with the experience,
the more we focus on the
employee culture and enjoyment
of everything, that
translates even more
into the guest experience, and
they have an even better time.
Because at the end of the
day, the server, the cook,
the manager, the
hostess, the dishwasher,
everyone is representing us.
So if they're not representing
us the proper way,
they're not translating
our vision to you.
And we want them to be happy.
And this is our house.
And so everyone in it is
welcome and happy in it.
But there definitely gets some
tension moments, you know?
I mean, we're
married, so we always
make it awkward sometimes.
SPEAKER 1: Well, I think
that's the perfect way
to end our time together.
We have some food coming out.
But before the food
touches your hands,
let's give a last
round of applause.
[APPLAUSE]